welcome back to the rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and in these final episodes of
Ahsoka some insane new Star Wars details
have emerged about my favorite character
of the series Ray Stevenson's Balin
skull a former Jedi who no longer reeks
a Jedi stink in the nostrils of the
death of Mary great mothers but since
it's a greater power calling to him from
peridia I'm gonna break down how valence
goal I think is the link between Star
Wars past present and future by the way
our Easter egg breakdown of episode 7
will upload to the new rockstars channel
on Wednesday and thanks so much for
supporting all of our Ahsoka videos in
recent days this series just took a hard
turn into Star Wars lore and it has been
so much fun to try to figure out what
the hell is going on with you all one
detail that I totally did not catch and
I have to shout out Nera 592 on Twitter
because I think they were the first to
see this balance wrist brace that we saw
in past episodes has some orabesh on it
and it can be hard to make out these
details because Disney plus initially
uploads these episodes with ridiculously
bad resolution in some cases but
nevertheless when Balin reaches for this
map sphere on the pedestal on ctOS near
592 spotted that you can see the orabesh
text in yellow on that wrist and they
translated that orabesh to the following
names Luke Leia Han Chewie R2D2 C3PO and
band now Ben could refer to Old Ben
Kenobi as this kind of would round out
the lineup of the Death Star sneaks in
that 1977 Star Wars film but Obi-Wan
never actually was grouped with them
once they rescued Leia he was kind of
doing his own thing on the Death Star
and all of them didn't share the same
space until that moment when he was
dueling Darth Vader and he looked over
and he saw them so the Ben on this list
could also be Ben Ben solo the son of
Leia and Han who will one day become
kylo Ren because the important thing to
know about this list is that all of
these characters if we consider Ben to
be Ben solo are currently alive in the
Star Wars historical timeline because
Ahsoka is set either in 9aby or 10 ABY
John Favreau and Dave filoni weren't
exactly clear about when the Mandalorian
season 3 took place but either way we
are during this new Republic era and all
of our main Star Wars characters at the
end of Return of the Jedi are alive and
well Ben solo would be around four or
five years old and this would be a few
years before his Uncle Luke would allow
him to train with him at that new Jedi
Academy that would later burn to the
ground when Palpatine via snoke reached
out to Young Ben solo and struck that
temple with lightning and Ben was kind
of blamed for it meanwhile Luke
Skywalker we know is building either
that Temple or a predecessor to it with
R2D2 and a bunch of those androids as we
saw in the book of Boba Fett chapter 6
episode 5 of Ahsoka mentioned what Leia
is up to Sandra rogana says she can only
give us cover for so long Senator Leia
Organa still at this point would be a
senator serving the new Republic but
years after this as we learn in Claudia
Gray's novel bloodline Leia's political
career will end when the truth gets out
that Darth Vader was her father
Chewbacca is likely with Han Solo
serving the new Republic in some way and
I think we can assume that C-3PO is
still serving Leia now again huge
prostitute Nera on Twitter for figuring
this out and to anyone else who may have
found this and translated it too the
best way to get into the Star Wars
spirit for Ahsoka is to pick up a tea
from our new World Series line we have
imagined a softball league from a galaxy
far far away with teams like kashyyk
Kessel and Beyond the designs come in
three quarter baseball shirts the wide
striped Sleeve football tees and in just
regular tees embrace the light and the
dark side of the nerd jock Spectrum at
the same time and if you're looking to
soak up Ahsoka you can grab the fulcrum
balance or Galactic graffiti tees for
your next watch party and if you think
nerd Riot isn't working on a really cool
line of designs for Loki season 2 you've
probably been eating too much of that
toxic green pie from the TVA break room
join the riot over at nerdriot.shop and
it's perfectly reasonable to interpret
this Eastern is just something that the
prop designer snuck in there maybe as a
nod to the original 77 Star Wars but who
knows since all these characters are
alive this could be a kind of hit list
for Balin would he describe Chewbacca as
Chewie and maybe not would he care about
the droids most definitely not what do
you know about a four or five-year-old
Ben solo and call him Ben okay I'm kind
of talking myself out of this one but
hey just remember balance goal remains a
man of mystery and we still don't know a
lot about his past as a Jedi but he did
know that Anakin Skywalker became Darth
Vader which is a very big deal and it
brings me to another big detail that I
definitely miss about bailen school's
costume over all these recent episodes
the green Crystal on his belt that might
be my might be the kyber crystal of his
original lightsaber one that could have
been green when he was still a Jedi this
has been going around on Twitter in the
days after episode six I've looked
around I think the first person on
Twitter at least I saw mentioning it was
someone named Logan Burns good job Logan
but there may have been others before
Logan but the reason it would be
interesting for Balon to keep his kyber
Crystal on his belt buckle is the still
unexplained reason his and Shin's
lightsabers glow orange Dave filoni
indicated that that was a deliberate
choice and that it was his way of
showing that Baylin and shin were not
Sith but were also not quite Jedi and
based on huyang's analysis of their
lightsaber hilts Balin kept his Hill
from when he was a Jedi but must have
replaced the kyber crystal that powers
it from the inside keeping a green
Crystal on his belt would be his way of
making sure no one else could weaponize
his old crystal in any other way but
also keeping it could explain balin's
softness for Ahsoka and for Sabine his
reluctance to outright kill them and
that choice definitely threw a wrench
into what thrawn expected and what the
three great mothers expected because
they called her a loose thread they
definitely did not see her coming now I
think all of these questions will be
answered when we finally learn what
press since Balin is sensing on paridia
there's something stirring that is
calling to him in my video last week I
theorized that this greatest power in
Star Wars could be bendu the mortise
gods or the priestesses from the
Wellspring of life but another option
that a lot of you have been asking me
about is abiloth an entity that I will
admit initially flew under my radar
because she's from an arc and legends
that I wasn't initially that familiar
with but some other great channels like
the den of nerds explored this
possibility in videos so I recommend you
check those out but just to quickly
explain to you hear who this is avaloth
was the villain in the Star Wars fate of
the Jedi novel series from 2009 to 2012
which ran concurrently with the Clone
Wars series abiloth began as a mortal
woman who served the three gods of
mortise aka the ones who were Immortal
manifestations of the celestials we know
them the Father the daughter and the son
but avaloth began as a mortal servant
and kinda ended up playing the three
against each other and Rose to power to
become the mother a deity in her own
right and you could say a sort of
balance among these three but was
totally evil because abella's Spirit was
awoken by Jason solo and Leia's son in
Legends when he becomes the Sith Darth
cadus Jason though as a character was
originally created by Timothy Zahn for
the thrawn trilogy heir to the Empire
and some say Jason solo influenced the
creation of the character kylo Ren
though you know if you know both
characters they are distinctly different
characters while these fate of the Jedi
books were categorized as Legends like
Han and Leia do not have a son named
Jason in Star Wars Canon many do
consider the character of abaloth and
the mother to be thematic background to
the canonical lore of the mortis Gods my
take on this is I just think this Ahsoka
series would already be taking a huge
leap to unveil live-action versions of
the Gods of mortis and then to go A Step
Beyond that to try to visually convey
and explain who abaloth is might just be
asking too much from ahsoka's viewership
two-thirds of whom I've been betting
didn't watch Clone Wars or Rebels and
like at least nine tenths of whom I'm
betting never heard of this beta the
Jedi storyline until they saw it on
YouTube that said I love that the fandom
is speculating because none of us know
right now in the lore from things like
the game Jedi fall in order is proving
to be important as the prettiest
Fortress was actually built by beans
from zepho this is going confirmed by
Tommy J Wall on Twitter who brilliantly
translated the Sith language of erkatai
that you can see on the portraits too
this phrase praise kuchit ruler of all
may his Reign last for all time and I
did explain in last week's video that
kujit was the name of a zepho sage and
ruler user of the dark side of the force
that they called the lifewind and you
actually visit his tomb in Jedi Fallen
order Zephyr were believed to have come
to this galaxy from another one and now
we know that the death of Mary Knight
sisters were at least linked with this
zepho ancient history as we continue to
watch this show I just think it's
important to let the show tell us what
it is and right now it is telling us
that this ancient power on paridia is
likely to at least be connected to the
zephonians or perhaps come from the same
Source where cujit and the zeppo derived
their power so we got two episodes left
of Ahsoka and it feels so great to be a
Star Wars fan right now please subscribe
to all three of our channels on the new
rockstars Network and you can support us
by grabbing some merch from
nerdrive.shop follow me on all social
studies follow me rockstars thanks for
watching and I'll see you tomorrow for
the Easter egg breakdown bye
[Music]
foreign